we've been looking at the normal
distribution and this is an amazing
shape because of how frequently it comes
up and one of the things that we
realized with it was that if you want to
understand the shape of this and
actually do some calculations you really
need to not just understand some of the
numbers some of the empirical data that
fits the normal distribution you also
need to know the probability density
function precisely so that you can start
to evaluate it you can use it to
calculate things like probabilities and
variants and all of the rest the only
problem was when we went through the
effort of trying to understand what
would be a graph that fits this
particular function and we ended up with
this graph here or this function one on
root 2 pi e to the negative 1/2 Z
squared which I mean we had to get take
some work to get there and it was it was
hard enough as it was before we realized
that to take this function and then
integrate it because integrating
probability density functions is kind of
a primary thing we do to evaluate
anything with them
you end up with something like this this
is the nightmare that you get when you
try and evaluate the cumulative
distribution function for the
probability density function of the
normal distribution it's pretty intense
to say the least so we want to do
everything we can to avoid having to
integrate this particularly manually and
so we decided that there were basically
three main strategies that we could use
to deal with this particular function we
could either use technology to evaluate
the integral directly or use the
trapezoid rule to get an approximation
and the same deal with a table of values
so what I'm going to show you is how you
can use technology to actually handle
this function and get for our purposes
the closest thing to a precise answer
that's possible for the normal
distribution so the way we're going to
explore this is by having a look at a
fairly lengthy questions so let's start
to think about it together there's a lot
to unpack as we go our highlight
information and write down what's
important so you've got a psychology
student who's investigating how
motivation influences performance I'm
just doing this experiment with rats
so the particular thing we have you look
at is on the
Maes that's being completed and the time
so I should underline these things the
times that are being recorded in order
to sort of get a sense of how quickly or
slowly these rats are going right now we
quit fairly quickly get some important
information here you've got a mean of 46
seconds so it's how long the average rat
takes to go through and then you've got
your standard deviation of 8 seconds
then comes the first question find the
probability that a randomly selected rat
completes the maze in less than 40
seconds all right so how are we going to
do this well what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna grab my normal distribution over
here and I'm going to impose some of the
information from the question onto onto
my graph of the normal distribution so
if I just paste this guy down here we
have a mean of 46 seconds that's the
first sort of numerical piece of
information that I get so that mean 46
seconds that represents the center of my
normal distribution so I'm gonna put in
here 46 seconds got that there and then
they start telling us things about the
standard deviation I've got a standard
deviation of eight seconds which means
as I go further and further out this
gives me Zed scores right so if I went
to say for example let's put it in nice
and close so that I can make sure that I
have enough space here I think that
should do all right so if I go one
z-score below the standard deviation
I'll stay with the same color and that's
eight seconds so that would land me at
38 seconds so I know that if I went one
standard deviation below and also if I
sort of duplicated that one standard
deviation above that would be 46 plus
eight is going to be 54 seconds so just
as an example between these two brown
bars and that would be 68 percent of the
population so there are some things that
I can just read off of this information
because I know the proportions but
immediately when I see these numbers
this is just one standard deviation out
I could go further I could go another
standard deviation below that would be
30 seconds it's choose another color
here and that would mean that I could go
up above as well and that would be
over here at +8 that'll be 62 seconds
the further I go out the more I can use
the ready numbers but the number that
we've been asked to measure the Pacific
time is about 40 right so you can see
over here I've got this particular
number 40 seconds and that doesn't sit
neatly on any of the integer z-scores
that I've got this would be an integer
z-score of negative 1 I might even write
that down because I think that's handy
to have
that's a Zed score of negative 1 and
then as soon as we go we've already gone
too far for the Zed score and negative 2
we've we've gone way past before he that
we wanted 40 would I guess be somewhere
in let's choose gring something is that
yeah I guess be somewhere around here
this would be where I expect to find 40
so what I'm being asked is what is the
probability that a randomly selected rat
completes the maze in less than 40
seconds so I'm being asked for the area
under the curve from 40 seconds over
here and then I have to go to the left
so you can see the area that's being
shared and it would just it would just
keep going over this way okay so how do
I evaluate this area since I don't have
nicely integer z-scores
I have to find out using technology what
this area is going to be so let's think
about how are we going to try to our
path through here I need a z-score that
corresponds to 40 because I need to know
what this spot is in terms of a z-score
the reason I want in terms of a z-score
is so that I can use this expression
over here rather than one that's in
terms of X and Sigma and that's much
messier right so I want to use my
probability density function in terms of
Zed so that's why I need a Zed score to
go into man okay so let's start marching
through this
I need a Zed score for this time of 40
seconds so I've got x equals 40 and the
question gave me values for mu and also
for Sigma our mean was 46 and our Sigma
was 8
so therefore the z-score that
corresponds to a time of 40 seconds
z-score is equal to X take away the mean
score take away the mean divided by
standard deviation so in this case we're
going to get 4
you take away 40 6/8 that's going to be
negative 6 on 8 so this is negative 3/4
and I will just quickly visually check
that a z-score of negative 3/4 is you
know sort of along my way to a z-score
of negative 1 but not all the way this
so this makes sense I know I've got a
z-score that's reasonable so how do I
then evaluate this integral and what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna say this is green
because I'm now working out this area I
want to form the integral that
corresponds to this area over here right
now I know what the upper boundary is
it's going to be this edge score that I
just worked out negative 3/4 that's my
z-score there so when i form the
integral it's going to end at negative
3/4 but then where does the integral
begin right I am sort of thinking about
where I start over here and one of the
things about the normal distribution is
its asymptotic to the x axis or the z
axis if that's what you're using so it
never hits there's no point of
intersection so I kind of need to say it
goes all the way from negative infinity
and then I have my probability density
function integrated with respect to Z
now I'm trying to use technology here to
help me and putting in substituting in
infinity is not going to be much use
here so what I want to do is pick an
appropriate value that's like negative
infinity that's sufficiently large over
this side that it might as well be
negative infinity and faithfully because
I'm getting technology to do this I know
to crunch the numbers myself so here's
what I'm going to do I'm going to pull
up the desmos over here because it will
handle definite integrals just fine so
let me put a side here and what I'm
going to do is I'm going to say for this
particular value here if I take a value
like something you know off on the
negative side like say negative 100
that's a really really far distance like
you imagine being a hundred standard
deviations below the mean that is going
to be close enough from a technology
point of view to be able to get an
approximate answer that is close enough
it's accurate enough I guess and then
I'm going to be substituting in my
probability density
function which is one on the square root
of two pi e to the negative 1/2 the Z
squared so that's what I'm going to be
substituting into let's see what the
technology makes of it so when I go
ahead I'm going to start by going to the
miscellaneous he comes my integral and
I'm gonna put in minus 100 for the lower
bound and then I'm going to go all the
way up if I can click on the right spot
to negative 3/4 so remember these are
Zed's cause we're dealing with here so
that's why I don't have you know 40
seconds or 46 seconds or things like
that I've got negative 3/4 which is the
corresponding z-score now I'm going to
put in the integrand which is my
probability density function it's one on
a square root of two pi multiplied by e
you gotta be really careful with your
typing here because it'll evaluate
exactly what you asked for
and if you ask for something incorrect
by typing wrongly and it'll just
evaluate that instead so I've got minus
1 over 2 and I'm dealing with Zed Zed
squared I'm just gonna check that that
looks pretty good to me and then I can
finish off my integral by providing the
variable of integration so there we go
I didn't have to do any trapezoid
overall and all that hard number
crunching by hand the technology has
done all of that for me so I'm gonna
write down this number this is zero
point two two six six two seven three
five I think that will do me just fine
I've got the number that I want and so
now I just go back to the question to
think about how do I use that number to
answer the question it says find the
probability that a randomly selected rat
completes the maze in less than the time
given right so normally we answer
probabilities in terms of like fractions
I guess you know it's like oh there's a
1/2 likelihood that this happens but
I've got such weird awkward numbers here
that the fractions are not going to do I
could just supply that decimal there
zero point two two six six etc that
would be fine but I think just as common
and maybe a little more easier to
understand and interpret for a human
being is to say I'll put that as a
percentage so that'll be twenty two
point seven percent if I did it to one
decimal place for percentages anyway so
if I ever think about this number I
always love to do a sense check where I
possibly can 22.7% does that look like
the area under the curve and I'm pretty
happy with that
remembering that the area underneath the
entire probability density function
should be a hundred percent that looks
roughly like a quarter to me anyway my
graph is not precise but I'm pretty
happy with that okay